what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i want to tell you guys something that i
learned from the manosphere
that made something make a lot of sense
in my life
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell for daily videos you're gonna be
notified of every single video okay
i'm gonna just jump jump right into it
so growing up
the thing that i've always like always
always always hated about myself
is i'm never the type to take charge in
a situation
um i
i've been in sports my whole life and
that was really where i found
my sense of self so to speak i was never
the type to have
you know um a boyfriend all the time or
i was never the type to be super good in
school so sports was
the one place that i found my sense of
self my sense of purpose
um and everything and in sports
you are rewarded if you take charge
and you are the leader and you
um are the one that's yelling at your
teammates and
you know calling people out whatever and
that was just never me i'm not
the type um so i
found myself getting overpassed for
captain positions and just
stuff that i wanted and felt like i
deserved um even though i was usually
one of the better players on the team
and
the older i get the more i realized that
the girls that were typically picked for
captain roles first
seemed to have more trouble in dating
and the girls that always were yelling
at everyone and always taking control
um they seem to be the girls that always
have more trouble in dating and what i
realized
is that my natural role as a woman
isn't to be in control it's to be second
in command
and i'm not saying like women can't be
in command or anything they totally
can't
it's just not me and um
yeah i always looked at it as a weakness
of mine and something i didn't like
um because i'm just the type of person i
love being behind a strong
captain i am super helpful i work hard
um but if i don't have a strong captain
in front of me i'm not the type that's
just gonna become the captain
um but it's kind of cool because the man
of sphere has made me realize that
that's not necessarily a bad thing
um it's probably gonna help when i get
married someday
and it's also the reason a lot of people
like me
um is that i'm pretty nice and easy
going
so i don't know um this is just a random
thought i had so if you're a girl even
though it's mostly men that watch me but
if you are a girl and you feel like
you're too nice you feel like people
just walk all over you
um they probably do and it happens but
it's also probably the reason you're
going to be successful in a lot of your
relationships
and um when you get married someday so
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys next time